president-elect joe biden has won
nevada's six
electoral votes this morning the state
supreme court approved county results
all but certifying the race
the final step for governor sisilak is
to sign off
so now no candidate can request a
recount but there are cases that have
already been filed and they're making
their way through the court system
the i-team's david charns joining us now
live from the newsroom with more on
those cases david
denise another busy day in court
attorneys for three republican
candidates who lost their elections
including president trump
making their cases to judges once again
today a judge rejected republican state
senate candidate april becker's request
for
a redo she lost her race as you see
there to state
senate leader nicole canazzaro by more
than 600 votes
that judge today saying throwing out the
election would disenfranchise other
voters
and he said he saw no evidence of any
widespread fraud
he also said canazarro should have been
named in the lawsuit
saying he also lacked jurisdiction in
this case now he also agreed with the
democrats attorney who said statements
collected by canvassers
should not be submitted as evidence
everything that the county commission
saw fit the grant
a new election for um is also present in
this district
by people knocking on doors and then
talking to people and then
writing down on a piece of paper what it
is that that person told them so that
they could then repeat it for the court
as the very description of that
indicates
that's classic hearsay congressional
candidate dan rodimer has the same
attorney you heard first there he lost
his race to congresswoman susie lee by
more than 12 thousand votes
his case will continue in court tomorrow
after he successfully had a new judge
assigned to that now in yet another case
today lawyers for the trump campaign
who said in that press conference last
week that the president
actually won the race have until next
week to present their evidence to a
carson city judge even though now all
these races are certified
this case will be heard the first week
of december and we'll stay on top of
that for you
i'm david charns 8 news now